oh this was uh
this is an interesting week in america
we have the oscars to honor the best
acting and then we had the supreme court
hearings
that witnessed the worst
did you see this [ __ ] that went down i
mean the republicans yes we're going to
have kentucky brown jackson is going to
be our first black woman on the supreme
court so that's
going to happen
but wow
to go through this charade
i mean i think the republicans were
still mad about brett kavanaugh from
2018. i mean if you took a drink every
time they mentioned brett kavanaugh
you'd be brett kavanaugh
uh
no but
judge jackson answered
tw
questions for 24 hours
over two days
uh just breaking the record from a
husband who was texting his ex
i mean she barely was able to keep the
what the [ __ ] are you talking about face
on
by the end i mean josh hawley you know
all these republicans you know implied
she was soft on child porn
uh tom cotton went on about how she was
coddling drug dealers ted cruz was
badgering about critical race theory
really nothing about saggy pants and
twerking
i mean if
if
you're the type of person who enjoys
watching older white people
yell at a black woman this was karen
heaven
marsha blackburn of tennessee actually
said word for word she said is it your
personal hidden
hidden agenda your personal hidden
agenda to incorporate critical race
theory into our legal system what do you
say to that
yep you got me whitey
that's what i'm here for yeah
i also want to put kanye
out to rushmore i mean
ted cruz of course has to be the worst
he asked her
based on this book called anti-racist
baby do you think babies are racist
which comes up all the time at the
supreme court
do you think and you know what babies
can be read that's actually kind of true
there is i mean not racist the way we
would define it but there is bias and i
know a baby who's racist
oh you can tell cause his first words
were i'm not a racist but
you